e aí galera beleza tudo com vocês ou
comigo está tudo bom não cara aconteceu
uma coisa muito muito trágica comigo eu
não vou fazer roteiros porque não jogou
direto nosso eu perdi o avião pra ir pro
esquenta de regina casé wilson gottardo
desde o início como foi que aconteceu
para você estava vindo e eu estava
ouvindo eu estava no ônibus com o meu
colega e eu recebi a ligação de um cara
na produção do esquenta o cara estava
interessado em levá la por causa da
paróquia o voto reprovado ainda não viu
o próprio meus vídeos aí tá aí que essa
página no artigo tinha pagar cinco
milhões de visualizações que o cara
gostou bastante acho legal falou pra
diretoria diretoria é com os diretores
lado o programa os produtores não leva
lá e acabou tudo certo deus te deu tão
certo que nem esperar uma semana do
semana e não foi à quadra
há uns três dias depois era pra mim eu
fiquei super animada fiquei super super
super animado tá no qual se lá cada um
programa nacional é show e aí chegou o
tão esperado dia poderei eu ia viajar 5
e 22 da manhã arrumei tudo deixe tudo
podendo me de 6 para acordar só enfiar o
pé nus no tênis e vazar foi aí que o
inferno começou
senhoras e senhores eu pra esse ano o
pior dia da minha vida
o alarme do meu celular não tocou a
música tudo ganha toda vez que eu vou
viajar para muito longe eu sempre fico
muito nervoso então eu passar a noite
inteira acordando tensão que já está na
hora sabe se a corda e 12 horas a idosa
agora três horas a idosa
acorda às 4 horas e eu tenho uma por
nenê ontem simplesmente aconteceu uma
coisa que nunca aconteceu comigo na
minha vida eu simplesmente dormir e
dormir se eu pego tente chamei o cara
que me deixar o aeroporto de moto e até
teria uma boa justificativa está no
roteiro se não tivesse uma casa que fica
atrás do aeroporto
só que até a pista aqui é entrada e eu
ficava aqui então tinha que dar a volta
no aeroporto entendeu pedir o cartão
deixar de moto já estava concluído tudo
pronto só coloquei a bolsa nas costa e
funk aeroporto quando chega do lado do
aeroporto no meio da pista a desgraçada
da mulher bateu a quina do carro em
alguma coisa não sei o quê não sei o que
ela simplesmente desce do carro pra ver
o que aconteceu cinco e pouco é a hora
em que os ônibus começam a circular
então começou a ficar ônibus hoje à
tarde onde à tarde o nikki quem toma na
rodinha eu preciso da moto ficou
rendendo ficou ele ficou o resto com ele
tava chovendo veio estava chovendo no
inter e zina piauí
choveu naquele dia fui planeta ficou nem
ficou em que cheguei onde cheguei no
porto nunca tinha entrado no aeroporto a
minha vida moça avião da gol voo rio de
janeiro como é que faz já não bastava tá
em tudo mal naquela madrugada a mulher
olha pra mim fala foi querido sem eu
perdi o avião pra ir pro esquento eu
perdi o avião pra ir pra esquisita
eu perdi o avião pra ir pro esquento
perdi avião pra esquentar
eu perdi o avião pra ir pro esquenta
tivesse repetição chata de perder o
avião para o esquenta que acabou de
passar
foi assim que meu juízo fico o dia
um tail o dia inteiro remoendo remoinho
sabe só pensava em não perder o avião
por beleza porto de avião
não eu perdi o avião pra ir pro schin
aí eu pego uma parte vai para casa e
penso por pedir um avião não tem nada
pior que possa acontecer não é não não
eu vou pagar o táxi carteira todos os
meus documentos cai no esgoto saae
catando a começar world esgoto pattana
enfia na carteira quando o montante foi
embora eu pensei será que eu devo
atravessar a rua não sei se debata essa
vai ter o morro né enfim atravessei não
morri graças a deus acabou por aí
não tá escutando andam tão não sabe o
que é gripe a gripe ou sabe se fica um
lado entupidos e respeito pelo outro
pois é gripe e enfim nos piores dias da
minha vida vocês precisarão saber disso
não vai mudar alguma coisa na vida de
vocês não na minha amiga assim que eu
tome tome tome o que você está pensando
totalmente já tinha preparado tudo casa
tinham preparado que eu ia falar ah eu
tinha um presente para dar a regina casé
essa blusa aqui o piauí
eu amo eu curto eu sei que vocês devem
estar pensando nisso mas você é um cara
novo você vai ter muito você vai ter
mais oportunidades você vai ter várias
chances na vida mais cara perde a chance
de divulgar seu trabalho em um programa
nacional é totalmente diferente o piloto
que você está pensando agora e esse
vídeo aqui tem uma finalidade toda
semana eu vim aqui postou um vídeo pra
vocês vocês se agradam sei que vocês dão
risada eu sei que vocês gostem e poxa
não é justo perder uma oportunidade
dessas porque simplesmente ser um dia de
azar da minha vida
cara eu nunca tive um dia desses eu
nunca tive um dia em que tudo deu tão
errado com a medida é só um jovem
sonhador
quem sabe que eu tenho muita vontade de
rádio e televisão além de sonhador gosto
muito do meu piauí sabe eu tenho muita
vontade de representar o piauí lá fora e
uma dessas formas seria entregando essas
duas pra gente na cadeia contar mais
sobre a história dos meus vídeos queria
pedir para vocês já que além de fãs
vocês são amigos de alguma forma me
torna bem próximo de você está
eu queria pedir a você aqui no primeiro
look
são aqui embaixo é a página oficial do
esquenta e o que vocês fossem na página
no um bote da página mas papai não nas
no status do amigo e pedisse para que eu
fosse lá coloca sei lá o link desse
vídeo fp comenta sei lá por que você
acha que o merece outra oportunidade de
lá com a stadium em arlington do
esquenta toda semana eu vim aqui com um
vídeo pra vocês e um sinal acho que eu
faço uma parte de você ser mais legal
então eu acho que essa é a hora de vocês
me ajudarem a entregar pessoalmente essa
camisa
para regina casé uma ajuda muito grande
você clicar aqui e gostei que isso faz o
vídeo se propagar
será que eu posso contar pra vocês é só
ir lá na página vai lá no bate-papo fala
alguma coisa com a hashtag um esquenta
começa por que você acha que eu mereci
na segunda vez eu nem fui o primeiro
gosto nem de lembrar cá comenta que
porque comenta por que você acha que eu
mereço a segunda chance de lá vai
entregar esta blusa pra ela é
se você gostou deste de blusa e eu tô
pôde piauí eu amo eu curto você se
interessou por algum tipo dessas camisa
em baixo da página do esquenta tem outra
página curtir a página e se informa
quando você faz pra adquirir uma das
camisas é isso se você puder me ajudar
muito obrigado clique que gostei se você
não está inscrito no canal nunca viu
nenhum vídeo meu é só você entra no meu
canal
houve aqui na bahia aqui do lado meus
vídeos o tenho certeza que você não vai
se arrepender
o meu twitter é esse aqui pode me seguir
se você quiser muito obrigado então
falou eu